metal air cells need to be lightweight
for many applications in order to
transfer more electrons with a smaller
mass
sodium and calcium are investigated as
potential anodes
a 1.0 gram anode of anode of which of
the and a 1.0 gram anode of which of
these metals would transfer more
electrons assuming that the anode is
totally consumed during the lifetime of
a cell justify your answer with
calculations
so let's go
to the top
where they showed the reactions
involving sodium and calcium and
actually let me just copy and paste this
so it's easier for me to reference near
the bottom where we're actually doing
the question
so let me just copy this
and then
let's paste it down here
that i can i can reference it
okay i'll even make it a little bit
smaller just so i don't take up too much
real estate
and so the reactions that we care about
are actually going to go in the reverse
direction of these half reactions
remember when we looked at when we
looked at our power source right over
here
this first half reaction is what
produces the hydroxide ions the
hydroxide ions migrate the way their way
to the left-hand side and then they
perform then they then they are involved
in oxidizing in oxidizing whatever metal
you have here if this was zinc the
hydroxide combines with the zinc they're
going to oxidize the zinc and those
extra electrons that are released in
that reaction those are the ones that
are going to travel across the wire and
provide the current but the hydroxide it
could react with sodium if this metal is
sodium it could react with calcium if
this metal is calcium so the reactions
we care about are going from this side
the right side to the left side
and so let me just rewrite that again
and actually just the act of rewriting
it will help well my pen is having
trouble
is having trouble actually scrolling
down but just the act of rewriting it
will help with digesting what's going on
so the sodium reaction for every two
molecules of sodium it's solid it's
actually forming our anode plus two
molecules of hydroxide
dissolved in the water aqueous solution
we are going to yield
sodium
sodium oxide
solid version of that
plus
water
in the liquid state and plus two
electrons and this is really important
because we want to think about
one gram of each of these metals how
many electrons would they yield how many
electrons are they going to uh are they
going to be able to transfer through
potentially through that wire so that's
the first relationship up there and then
actually let me just leave the sodium
there and then let me do the calcium
over here remember we want to go from
the right to the left so let me rewrite
it that way
calcium
solid state
plus two hydroxides
dissolved in water
is going to yield calcium oxide
solid
plus liquid water
liquid
plus
two
electrons so once again i just rewrote
each of these in the opposite direction
and if i were to write the voltage i
would flip the sign now because i have
written them in the other in the other
direction but they're not asking us
about the voltage they want us to know
what a 1 gram anode of which of these
metals would transfer more electrons so
if we think about sodium
the case with sodium
we have 1.0 grams
1.0 grams
of sodium
well let's think about how many moles of
sodium that is
well that's going to be
well let's see we're going to have
we can look
we can look up sodium on our periodic
table of elements and this is actually
the one that they give you when you take
the ap test and you see sodium right
over here we could read its atomic
weight sometimes now called relative
atomic mass and that's the weighted
average of the atomic masses of the
isotopes that you would typically find
of sodium on earth if you just took a
random sample of sodium and you were
average the atomic masses it would be
22.99 so that tells us that a mole of
sodium is going to weigh it's going to
have a mass of
22.99 grams
or
you could say
so a mole
is going to
a mole is going to have a mass of
22.99 grams so i could write one
mole
one mole of sodium is going to have a
mass
of
22.99
grams and of course this is still
talking about sodium and so i made sure
that i have it in terms of moles per
gram
because when you do our dimensional
analysis grams divided by grams or grams
of sodium divided by grams of sodium
they're going to cancel out and i'm
going to be left with moles of sodium so
this part of the expression this is
going to give me how many moles of
sodium we are dealing with if i have one
gram of sodium
but we need to think about how many how
many electrons how many electrons are we
going to be able to are we going to be
able to transfer and that's where we
actually have to look at this reaction
so for every two
for every
two moles of sodium we are going to
transfer two moles of electrons or
another way you can think about it is
for every mole here you have a two to
two relationship or you could say for
every mole of sodium we are going to
transfer one mole of electrons and so
let's do that we're going to transfer
one
mole
one mole of let me write it this way
one
mole
of electrons
per
mole
per mole
of sodium if you have two moles of
sodium you're going to get two moles of
electrons if you have one mole of sodium
you're going to have two if one mole of
sodium you're gonna have one mole of
electrons and so what is this going to
give us
well if you just multiply out actually
let's look at the units first grams of
sodium cancel out with grams of sodium
moles of sodium cancel out with moles of
sodium and so you're left with just
moles of electrons
moles
of
why am i putting an apostrophe moles of
electrons it's going to be 1.0
times 1 divided by 22.9 times 1.
so it's 1.0 divided by 22.9 and let's
see i'm going to have two significant
digits right over here two significant
figures so let me get
get the calculator out
and it is let's see so it's just one i
could just say one divided by 22.9
is equal to
so if we have two significant figures
it's approximately
zero four
four
point zero four four
so i'll say approximately
zero point zero
four four
moles of electron remember moles
avogadro's numbers this is still a lot
of electrons the mole is 6.022 times 10
to the you know roughly that times 10 to
the 23rd so it's a very very large
number of electrons that we are going to
potentially transfer over here if we
have one gram of sodium now let's do the
same thing with the calcium
so if we have calcium it's going to be
the same exercise here
we have one
gram
of calcium
times
one mole
of calcium has what mass
one mole of calcium has a mass of how
many
of how many grams
so let's go back to the periodic table
and there you have calcium right over
here the atomic weight is 40.08 or often
times are now the more modern name is
relative atomic mass the weighted
average of the typical of the isotopes
40.08 so i can write
40.08 right over here
and then in our reaction for every mole
of calcium how many moles of electrons
are we going to generate
well we have in this reaction one for
every one calcium we have two electrons
so for every mole of calcium we're going
to have two moles of electrons so we
could say times two
moles
of electrons for every
mole of calcium in our that we have as a
as a reactant over here
and so this is going to give us this is
going to be approximately
see our units
grams of calcium cancels with grams of
calcium moles of calcium cancel with
moles of calcium
and so we're going to have 1 times 1
divided by 40.08 times 2. so it's going
to be 2 divided by 40.08
which is
so
divided by
40.
and we're gonna have two significant
figures right over here because this two
and those ones are kind of pure numbers
while these are from measurements so
this is the fewest number of significant
figures so we have two
so 2
divided by that let's see so it's going
to be 0.050
so 0.050
moles
of electrons
so you can see right from right from
this calculation that the one gram of
calcium has the can can can
transfer more electrons than one gram of
sodium if sodium was the anode so we see
very clearly that calcium
so one
gram of calcium
can
transfer more electrons
can transfer
more electrons
than
1.0
gram
of sodium you can see it right over here
we have done
the
calculation